since making his debut as a dark night
in 2016 s Batman vs Superman dawn of
Justice Ben Affleck's name has become a
synonymous with Batman as Jared Leto's
house with the Joker Margot Robbie's
house of Harley Quinn and gal gadot has
with Wonder Woman affectionately
referred to as buff Fleck by fans of his
contributions to the DC extended
universe Affleck puffed out his chest
mustered up some courage and assumed the
mantle once occupied by screen icons
Adam West Michael Keaton Val Kilmer
George Clooney and The Unforgettable
Christian Bale who led Christopher
Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy now Affleck
is hanging up his cape and cowl and
handing the suit over to someone now
someone who could be Robert Pattinson
yes rumor has it that Warner Brothers is
eyeing the Twilight Saga alum to become
the next Batman making his first
appearance and director Matt Reeves as
the Batman the longest dating film that
Affleck was initially supposed to lead
since appearing in Twilight Pattinson
has established himself as a legit actor
with acclaimed roles in the film's high
life and good time and the internet is
noticed taking such a liking to the idea
of Pattinson as Batman that digital
artists have started creating artwork
imagining what the British star would
look like all done up as a Caped
Crusader using a Batman concept suit
designed by 3d generalist and CG artist
Krista Flaco Twitter user Nova MCU
shared their creation on the site On
February 11th Pattinson is just one of
many names allegedly in the running for
the world of Batman revenge of the fans
editor in chief Mario Robles claimed on
an episode of his the fanboy youtube
series Pattinson was up against the
likes of kick-ass star Aaron
taylor-johnson
Lone Ranger lead armie hammer and Game
of Thrones stars Richard Madden and Kit
Harington
among many others but it's Pattinson
that seems to have really captured
people's imaginations boss logic wrote a
choice that I never would have thought
to try but I've been hearing some
background chatter about Robert
Pattinson being looked at if the source
is true and all of our predictions were
wrong this might be your new Bruce it
goes without saying that this is all
hearsay
grapevine gossip unconfirmed chitchat
floating around the internet Warner
Brothers hasn't confirmed or denied
reports of Pattinson becoming the next
Batman and director Reeves hasn't made
so much as a peep about who the next
Batman might be the studio is apparently
looking for someone younger than Affleck
to portray Batman next with the Batman
set to center around a young
version of the famous DC Comics hero
Pattinson it's only 32 to a flex 46 and
that 14 year age gap falls almost
perfectly in line with past reports that
claimed Warner Brothers once at newest
iteration of Batman to be 15 to 20 years
younger than Affleck and the character
to be between 25 and 30 years old in the
movie if Warner Brothers decides to go
older though Pattinson might face some
serious competition from a couple of
established superstars namely Jake
Gyllenhaal and Jon Hamm Gyllenhaal has
been a top contender for the role of
Batman in the past and though in 2018 he
denied he would be the next Batman
things can change pretty fast in
Hollywood and us for Hama he's
reportedly been campaigning for the role
for a long time
back in December 2017 radar online cited
a source I claimed John knows Ben has
faced some criticism over Batman vs.
Superman and Justice League and frankly
things would be better suited for the
job
this is business for John not personal
the writing's on the wall and John's
desperate for the gig since Gyllenhaal
is 38 and Hammes 47 it seems unlikely
that either of the two men will end up
leading the Batman but who knows after
Christian Bale left the role nobody was
expecting Ben Affleck to take over so
now that Affleck is leaving who knows
what Warner Brothers will decide it
could even be some other name nobody was
expecting to hear
either way the studio is scheduled the
Batman to soar into theaters on June
25th 2021 so fans should expect that
announcement soon about which actor will
play the part
whether it's Pattinson or not check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite superheroes are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]